j'étais évidemment heureux que celui
pour qui je m'étais prononcées et qui a
obtenu mon vote est une aussi large
victoire c'est vrai mais en même temps
on était dans la même famille donc le
nom le vrai ce qui m'a vraiment rendu
heureux si vous voulez savoir c'est le
fait que au final ce qui a payé c'est le
travail de la persévérance la constance
dans les idées le courage de dire les
choses comme elles sont ce discours de
vérité c'est c'est ça finalement qu'il
m'a dit m'a donné le plus de
satisfaction c'est un bel exercice
démocratique parce que il ya au moins
une chose qui est certaine c'est que
françois fillon n'aurait pas été
qualifié par les républicains pour être
leur candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et donc au lieu d'être un
choix de partir dans un conclave plus ou
moins obscures on a eu le choix qui a
été fait les suites d'une campagne
électorale et qui amène un second tour
qui était très honnêtement le second
tour que auquel personne ne pensait il
ya encore prends moi quand on voit le
score de françois fillon se dit que
finalement tout ce qui est même si c'est
assez loin maintenant bilan du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy et de
françois fillon n'est pas rejetée par
les électeurs c'est surtout une question
de personne je soutiendrai françois
fillon je l'avais soutenu pour la
présidence de l'ue manger et c'est
quelqu'un qui va préparer une créa
l'alternance qui va qui a un bon projet
qui va savoir analyser les difficultés
de france qui a l'expérience du plus
haut niveau il était pianiste cinq ans
dans une période extrêmement difficile
il sait rassembler la montre et donc
aucune raison qu'il ne soit pas un bon
candidat pour la droite ex entre l'année
prochaine et ensuite un excellent
pendant le faisait remarquer